>>Chris DiBona: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to I think the last segment of the
day; right?
I hope you have had a great time here at I/O.
It's something that we put a lot of work into
as a company.
I mean, not me personally, but we put a lot
of work into it as a company, and it represents
the end of -- not the end, but, well, an important
point in a lot of our release schedules and
careers and the rest, as you saw with this
morning's discussion about Froyo.
>>> (Speaking off mic)
>>Chris DiBona: No, a high point. It's all
downhill from here, David.
What I would like to do is I would like to
have the esteemed panel introduce themselves
very quickly, starting with David.
>>Dave Sparks: Dave Sparks. I am the lead
on the Android Media Framework.
>>San Mehat: I am on the Android Kernel Team.
>>Michael Morrissey: Michael Morrissey. I
am the director of Android Services.
>>Dan Morrill: I am Dan Morrill. I am the
open source and compatibility lead.
>>Dan Bornstein: I am Dan Bornstein. I am
the tech lead for the Dalvik team.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: I am Xavier Ducrohet. I
am the lead for the SDK and developer tools.
>>Brian Swetland: Brian Swetland. I am the
Android systems kernel lead.
>>Mike Cleron: Mike Cleron, and I work on
application framework and system UI.
>>Chris DiBona: Oh, and this is an Android,
so.... They couldn't see it over on the other
side. So it's a huge plush Android.
>>Dave Sparks: Isn't that Andy Rubin?
>>Chris DiBona: This is Andy Rubin.
Actually, Andy and a lot of the team are in
the back. Scream out, "Yo!"
>>>Yo!
>>Chris DiBona: Yo.
So they are all here in case there is something
we can't answer, or answer incredibly poorly,
they will be here for that.
We have got questions on the bit.ly link there,
and we also have mics in the room. So if you
have question at this point, you are better
off going to the mic. So let's get started.
I am Chris DiBona. I run a number of open
source programs at the company, and I work
with the Android team.
So there you go.
What can Google do to improve the transparency
of Android core code development, deployment
and design? Google code trackers are full
of questionable actions: Tickets closed without
remarks or defects closed as work-as-intended.
So this is sort of a softer question.
This isn't really like how do you power on
this rail.
San, you look like you want to say something.
>>San Mehat: There's a lot of stuff on the
issue tracker, and I think that -- we as developers
do our best to keep track of stuff and we
have our internal bug tracker as well as external
bug trackers and sometimes for various reasons
it may not make sense to update one versus
another but I think we are trying to do better
at that. So I think you are going to find
there is a concerted effort being made by
engineering to get more involved in that.
>>Dan Morrill: So I don't know when this question
was entered, but you may have noticed that
last night we pushed a new version of the
source.Android.com site which addresses actually
some of these issues.
As San pointed out, this is not something
this is not something that's news to us. We
have known for some time that the contents
of the source.Android.com site have been a
little not up-to-date.
So we refreshed all that content for calm
of different reasons. Someone to include compatibility
information about the Android compatibility
program, but also to include a refreshed version
of the kind of, you know, basics of the open
source project that is Android in terms of
how we do code reviews and so on.
In addition to that, we are also spinning
up a bunch of different work that you will
start see rolling out over the coming months,
including some ways to do better about handling
our issue tracker.
As many of you probably know, like any OEM,
we have our internal issue tracker where we
use to track issues with the devices that
we work on and so on. And one thing we are
working on doing is synchronizing the public
and internal system so we can have better
consistency between the two and so on.
So take a look at the site. There is a lot
of stuff on that site, so I guess I will just
defer to the stuff that we wrote recently.
I am happy to take follow-up questions or
see you guys online and so on.
>>Chris DiBona: Why don't we take a question
from this microphone.
>>> Thanks. Right now anybody can go out and
download some paid apps on online because
they have been pirated. What are the plans
to improve copyright protection in the Android
marketplace for apps?
>>Michael Morrissey: That's a very good question
and one we hear a lot, and I don't want to
pre-announce anything, but we are working
on things internally to address those problems.
So stay tuned. I think you will hear more
in the near future.
>>Chris DiBona: Let's go to this microphone
on the left.
>>> My name is Frank maker. I am a graduate
student at U.C. Davis.
I do a lot of work with Android and eclipse
is really painful. So I was wondering if you
guys had any thoughts on how to --
[ Applause ]
>>> I am seriously considering getting a new
computer just because, you know, if you work
on eclipse for three or four hours, you have
to restart it.
So I know you guys know this is a problem
so I am wondering if you have any thoughts
right now on how to update it.
And the other question I had real quick is
how close you are to putting Android back
into the Linux kernel tree.
>>Brian Swetland: Let's answer the second
question first.
>>Chris DiBona: Totally.
>>Brian Swetland: Well, I mean, my -- I don't
use eclipse. I am a kernel engineer, so I
can't help you with the first part. Somebody
else can dive in afterwards.
We are actively working with the Linux kernel
community to try to move more stuff upstream.
If you have been following on the Linux kernel
mailing list, there's been four weeks of discussion
around the last six rewrites of the wakelock
or suspend lock or API. If it's going to get
merged, it's going to get merged. We are putting
some effort into working with upstream folks.
But, you know, it will get there when it gets
there.
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah, I mean one of the realities
of the kernel is it's hard to hurry, you know.
But we kind of came to a meeting of minds
of some sort at the Linux convention a couple
of -- what was that? A month ago now? Yeah.
And it was a good meeting.
But I anticipated it would take much longer
to get to this point so I am cautiously optimistic
at this point. Whereas before I was, oh, it's
open source. Huh.
And about Eclipse. Who wants to hate on Eclipse?
>>Xavier Ducrohet: We are aware that Eclipse
requires a lot of resources, and that's why
we are paying a lot of attention to make sure
you have another way of developing for Android.
You don't have to use Eclipse.
We provide an Ant script. DDMS works as a
developer application tool. We are making
sure that you can do everything outside of
Eclipse if you don't want to use it. And then
after, I mean if you want, you can try to
use net bins. There's the plug-in for it.
IntelliJ has two part for it. If you really
want an ID, you can try something else. But
we can't support all of them, so we are going
to pay more attention to Eclipse at this time,
but we are also making sure that you can use
either VI or whatever you want.
>>> I think to that effect, it would really
help if you pointed out some of those options
because I am familiar with those because only
after being frustrated with Eclipse I went
and looked for something else. But I think
a lot of people don't know there are other
options so you might want to make those options
available.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Yeah, we can probably link
from our developer site to those.
>>> Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: And the question that's likely
for Dave Sparks, what plans are there to improve
the media experience on Android, lack of equalizer,
limited video CODECs, stock music and video
players, browser quite limited.
>>Dave Sparks: I didn't hear you will of that.
>>Chris DiBona: You know where that one is
going.
>>Dave Sparks: We actually, in the previous
thing I was in about an hour ago or something
like that, we were talking about some of the
roadmap stuff, and we are going to be supporting
open SL ES as an API. So this is in the Khronos
open standard. And that includes effects processing.
You will start to see effects processing in
the next release.
>>Chris DiBona: And plug-ins for the effects
if you decide to go write them and put them
on the market. It's actually really nice because
on Android we will have one of the first fully
open sourced SL ES implementations, which
we are hoping will drive innovation across
platforms.
Yeah.
Let's take another one from the room. This
fellow here.
>>> Hello. I live in Switzerland, and I also
come from Sweden and I was wondering when
I can create a merchandise account for Sweden
and/or Switzerland.
And I have a second question. I have an application
deployed on the market that, for some reasons,
a couple of users can't see, even though I
have it from SDK 1.5 and for all languages.
>>Chris DiBona: I couldn't hear the first
question. The second one sounds like he have
has an application he targeted in 1.5 but
some users are still not seeing it on the
market.
So it might be about market selectivity based
on the platform?
Anything?
This is kind of like -- actually, in some
ways I would recommend office hours for this
kind of question because it's hard to drill
down to your particular application in this
environment. So maybe talk to them afterwards
about that one.
What was your first question again?
>>> When can I create a merchandise account
in Switzerland and/or Sweden for earning money
for applications on Android Market.
>>Michael Morrissey: So we're actively working
to expand market seller and buyer support
in many different currencies and countries.
Right now, I think we have buyer support in
13 countries and seller support in ten, and
we are looking to expand that a lot.
There is a lot of complicated issues around
that, but we are doing it as fast as possible
and we are prioritizing based on geography
and the number of devices and the number of
developers in each country.
>>> Would it be possible to get a date for
Switzerland?
Laugh.
>>Michael Morrissey: No, I'm sorry, not right
now.
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks.
How about the fellow in red right here.
>>> A little while back we wanted to have
our app call out to another third-party app.
It was quite painful searching around. I finally
ended up going to their forums and posting
up the questions to see what kind of intents
their app listened to on the device.
So I finally got that answer, but what can
Google do to facilitate that third-party integration
between apps in the future?
>>>
>>Chris DiBona: So corralling the intents.
Dan, want to take that one?
>>Dan Morrill: So, again, this is something
that we are aware of. And what we would like
to do is create a -- well, there's really
two parts to this question. What it really
boils down to is that, in fact, we talk about
this in the compatibility definition document
on the source.Android.com site, but basically
intents as a group or a concept represent
essentially sort of the soft API and we need
to make sure that devices that are -- well,
intents are provided by applications. We need
to make sure that devices that are implementing
Android all provide the same set of intents
but we also want to extend that to third-party
apps.
So the challenge that we have, and this is
something that I am actually thinking over,
although I don't have any necessarily concrete
plans here yet, is to come up with a kind
of site or service where developers can publish
the intents that their applications expose
essentially for use by other applications.
And in the same site, include the standard
system intents so developers have a one stop
shop for finding this kind of information.
Like I said, that's not something that we
have, you know, ready for launch or anything
like that.
It's not clear whether that belongs in the
SDK documentation or a separate site or something
like that.
But it's definitely something we're thinking
about.
>>Chris DiBona: All right.
>>> (Off mike).
>>> Open Intents is what this fellow said,
in case nobody caught that.
>>Dan Morrill: Sorry.
I didn't catch that.
>>> (Off mike.)
>>Dan Morrill: That's true, openintents.org
actually does have a good database as a start.
And we've been looking at that as well.
I actually haven't looked at it terribly recently.
But they're a good resource for starters.
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks.
So the Android Market is growing at an exponential
rate.
But the payoff is that most of the growth
is coming from spammers.
I don't know that I agree.
eg, quote, app developers.
Does the Android team plan to do something
about it, maybe let the user filter out apps/developers?
Like an I hate button.
>>Michael Morrissey: I reject the premise
that most of the growth is coming from spammers.
>>Chris DiBona: One person's book production
mechanism is another person's spammer.
You know.
>>Michael Morrissey: Good point, Chris.
But, yes, we're always looking for ways to
improve discoverability in -- of applications
in the Android Market.
And that means, you know, ranking things lower
that aren't good for people and ranking things
higher that a lot of people like.
So we're always tweaking those algorithms
and looking for ways to improve.
>>Chris DiBona: Thanks.
Over here I think.
>>> Hi.
I have three small questions about the Android
future.
The first one is Froyo --
>>Chris DiBona: Make it all one question,
one big, complicated question, then.
Because there are a lot of people.
>>> Just ask for three feature, the first
is about FM radio support.
The second is more about radio telephony support.
And the last one is support multiple display
hardware, for example, two LCD.
>>Chris DiBona: Okay.
The first one was what?
Sorry.
>>> About FM radio support.
>>Chris DiBona: Actually, we have FM radio
support in the EVO?
>>David Sparks: Manufacturers are doing their
own thing on FM radio.
We've looked at a couple of proposals from
-- from a couple different partners.
We don't have anything we like yet.
But I think we'll probably have something
next year.
>>Chris DiBona: Number two?
>>David Sparks: Number two was -- was it,
like, DTV or something like that?
>>> About radio telephony.
>>David Sparks: VT?
>>> Yeah.
>>David Sparks: So we don't have anything
specific if you're talking about, like, H324M.
We are definitely looking at video chat interfaces.
But I think what we'll be able to do in the
very near future, probably the next release,
is enable those sorts of applications where
you provide your own VT stack and you can
integrate with a media framework.
>>Chris DiBona: And then multiple screens
was the other one?
>>> Yeah.
>>David Sparks: So multiple screens is a longer-term
problem.
And I don't know if I should let Mike talk
-- there's framework issues and there's the
-- the low-level issues.
It's a complicated problem which affects the
entire stack if you're going to do it correctly.
So there's stuff that we have to do on the
framework side and there's stuff we have to
do on the system-level side.
We'll probably do something in the interim
to enable specific applications like playing
video on an external display, but not deal
with the -- trying to run applications across
multiple displays at the same time.
>>Mike Cleron: In general, we're trying to
support the center of gravity for device profiles.
So we have broadened our support for application
-- for devices a lot over the last year.
We're continuing to look at what the new and
emerging device profiles are that are coming.
For multiple screens, that's on our radar,
but I wouldn't say it's quite the center of
gravity yet.
So I think what we're going to aim for there
is some kind of, you know, minimal support
that enables OEMs to -- to run with it, but
we may not provide that as core functionality
of the platform.
>>> Okay.
Thanks.
>>Chris DiBona: What does the Android team
have planned with regards to implementing
hardware and peripheral functionality like
HID and USB host/on the go?
>>Brian Swetland: do you mean USB HID or
-- Oh, this was off the -- I guess they can't
tell me.
Oh, well.
>>Chris DiBona: I'm not coming up with these
questions, you know.
>>Brian Swetland: I'm easily confused.
>>Chris DiBona: Bluetooth HID.
>>Brian Swetland: So Bluetooth HID we experimented
with before.
I think we'll see it in an upcoming release.
Certification for Bluetooth is fairly involved.
So getting it going so it'll start working
and getting it actually certifiable is a bit
more work.
But it'll be coming in the future, I believe.
USB OTG is also -- there's ongoing work around
it.
I think both these things are likely to turn
up in the Gingerbread time frame.
But, you know, it's the future.
>>Chris DiBona: I think we're on this side
now, yeah.
>>> Thank you.
In my opinion, it seems like the maps API
is ripe for some improvements.
There are a lot of things that developers
all across the ecosystem are having to reimplement.
It seems like it would be nice to be able
to register overlay tile servers with the
framework and have it manage the cache of
the tiles since it has to manage a cache of
tiles for the base map, seems like scatters
of points are logical things.
There's lots of new features showing up in
the map application that seems like they would
be nice to expose to developers.
So I was wondering if you could address the
plans for the maps API.
>>Mike Cleron: Yes, you're right.
You're right on all points.
That's an area that has been a little underserved.
And we now have someone there that that's
his job is to bring that up to the level that
we want it to have.
So we're -- that's something that we've just
put a lot more energy into.
And you should be seeing results of that in
the next platform release.
>>Chris DiBona: Okay.
Thanks.
I think the push question was sort of answered
this morning.
So you.
>>> So I'm a strong believer of Android.
However, I saw some competition from Chrome.
I'm wondering, is there any plan to improve
the compatibility between two platforms, for
instance, running Android apps at Chrome or
running a full Android -- Chrome browser at
Android platform.
Thank you.
>>David Sparks: So I mean, it's really, really
early in this, but we're definitely talking
with the Chrome team, particularly thinking
about native client and how that might apply
to Android.
But this is way -- this is not the next release.
This is probably sometime next year.
But we're definitely thinking about that issue.
We want to make it easy for application developers
to port to Chrome, Chrome OS, and Android,
and minimize the amount of work you need to
do.
I don't think we can make it completely go
away, because you have different platforms
you have to deal with.
The idea of having an application that can
run seamlessly on a small device and a television
or something like that.
You'll get some functionality.
There's probably some work that you'll need
to do.
But we do want to make it easy to port the
app.
>>Chris DiBona: I think the market question
was kind of answered this morning.
Do you guys want to say anything about market
improvements?
You're good?
Let it rest.
Also, will Froyo be available in the Nexus
One?
>>> Will it?
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah.
So there's your answer.
Oh, when.
Sorry, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Sorry.
It's the hot lights, you know.
When?
>>Dan Bornstein: Soon.
>>> Soon.
>>David Sparks: We traditionally put out the
SDK not too long before it goes to devices.
So that should give you a clue.
We aren't in complete control of everything,
because we have to work with carriers and
things like that.
>>Mike Cleron: Before it starts getting cold
again.
>>Chris DiBona: We kind of already answered
the copy protection question.
Currently, copy protection doubles your APK
size and protected apps.
It routinely is hacked.
We kind of answered that already.
Let's go to this side, stripey.
It's a striped shirt.
I can't see much from here.
>>> Okay.
So I was wondering why the framework API,
like, isn't separate from the entire platform
and if, like, at some point in the future
we can see, like, updates of the API that
don't rely on, like, carriers updating their,
like, code and, like, sending out updates,
sort of like how we have Java or dot net on
a Windows platform that are pretty much independent
of the OS, like, to some degree at least.
>>Mike Cleron: If I understood the question,
it was why is the framework bound to OS releases?
>>> The API, basically.
The API.
So, like, if -- if at some point, like, the
API will, like -- we'll have new APIs that
we can just install on, like, Android --
like, version 2.2, like we can install later
versions even if, like, someone else is running
2.5.
>>Mike Cleron: Well, we're making an active
effort to separate the applications from the
framework.
So you'll be seeing application updates coming
much more frequently than OS updates.
But from our perspective, the framework is
the OS.
And we -- they're not separable for us at
a technical level right now.
We can't really change the -- you know, the
activity API without changing the activity
manager, which is part of the OS.
So those two are going to remain bundled together,
probably forever.
>>Chris DiBona: Other stripey.
>>> Hi.
Yeah, I guess this goes back to the question
about device profiles and your discussion
on that.
I'm from Intrinsic and we imported Android
to a number of non-phone devices.
So struggled with some of the architectural
problems like you mentioned about multiscreens,
and, specifically, devices that might not
have a modem or have a modem that's not always
powered on and you might want to power it
off while the device is in standby.
And there's a number of other issues like
that, like different screen technologies that
might not be LCD-based screens.
So are there any approaches towards devices
that aren't sort of phone-based, especially
given the Google TV thing this morning?
>>Brian Swetland: To take part of the question,
powering the modem off while on standby is
doable today.
It's a policy decision you can make, if --
>>> Perhaps based on whether the application
needs data or not.
When the phone is actually on or when the
device is on.
I shouldn't say phone, because it's a nonphone
device.
When the device is on and you don't want to
have the modem powered up, but only when you
need it for data.
>>Brian Swetland: Okay. I don't think I understand
the question, then.
>>Chris DiBona: I think he wants more flexibility
around program ability and subparts.
>>>Profile of the device, assuming that there's
a modem there.
>>Chris DiBona: It's kind of an unanswerable
question, you know, because a lot of their
work is going to concentrate on sort of the
very mobile experiences.
So that's sort of the result of the profiles.
You've seen other companies, Barnes & Noble,
Archos, and others, address other niches,
and in some cases quite well.
If you look at the NOOK, it does multiple
screens and very odd power profiles.
But it's a custom device.
>>> That was actually our work in doing the
platform.
>>Chris DiBona: That was your work?
Great.
>>> Well, in doing some of the platform porting.
So of the -- the way that the modem is controlled.
But there's actually a lot of architectural
change you have to make in order to do that.
So I was just wondering if you're actually
targeting devices that aren't phone or phone-oriented?
>>Mike Cleron: I'll take a stab at this.
We have two conflicting goals, which are both
positive things but they don't always align.
We want to maximize the reach of Android for
the greatest number of devices possible, and
we don't want all the developers in the room
to have their heads explode trying to support
every possible configuration.
So if somebody manages to get Android running
on their tennis shoe, you know, good for them.
But we're probably not going to support, you
know, tennis shoe-specific APIs in the framework,
because we'll have app compatibility problems.
So CTS is kind of the tool that we use to
define that.
That's where we're saying that this is what
is the essence of Android.
In order to be Android device, you need to
support all the APIs in CTS.
I'm maybe speaking a little bit out of turn,
but we're always trying to improve that and
tighten the focus of that so we capture the
things that matter versus the things that
don't matter.
So there's -- Android is running on a surprising
number of devices, or at least surprising
to me.
Every day on Gizmodo, I see it running on
something else I didn't expect.
>>Chris DiBona: Microwave.
>>Mike Cleron: Microwave, yes.
So I think over time, we'll try to improve
the ability of innovation to happen in the
field by not requiring things that don't matter
to the core of the platform, but we're always
going to be tempering that by making sure
that developers have a clear path to knowing
when they're done and knowing what the range
of devices they have to support is.
We're always trying to navigate that.
We can look to the developer community to
help us with that, you know, if we get a message
from you that there's an emerging class of
devices, there's an emerging problem that
we're not serving well, then that's feedback
we can take and we can try and extend the
platform to match that or extend CTS to match
the problems that you're trying to solve.
>>Dan Morrill: Yeah, and just to kind of follow
up on that, there's actually -- this is the
compatibility-related content that I referred
to earlier that's on source.android.com.
So there's actually two things that you can
take a look at if you want to see this spelled
out in detail.
There's a new page on the SDK developer.android.com
site if you're an app developer that may be
of interest which summarizes -- it's called
compatibility considerations for developers.
But it summarizes what you have to do to make
sure that your app will run as widely as possible.
And also kind of explains from a developer
point of view what the compatibility strategy
is.
And then, of course, there's this compatibility
section on the new site that talks in toilet
gory detail about all this stuff.
But, in general, basically, we just have two
key mechanisms that we use.
We use this compatibility definition document,
you know, which basically says what devices
can do and not do to be considered compatible,
and then there's a CTS which, you know, verifies
that -- and helps them make sure that their
devices are behaving correctly.
And these two things together are the foundation
for what we call an Android compatible device.
So Android is open source, and people are
welcome to use it for whatever they want.
We love when we see that. But from our point
of view, that kind of thing exists outside
the application ecosystem.
>>Chris DiBona: There's a question on the
thing about when were we going to see proxies,
HTTP proxying. And battery optimization.
So proxies.
>>> Support for?
>>Chris DiBona: Support for.
He uses exclamation points.
>>> They are question marks, Chris.
>>Chris DiBona: Oh, question marks. They are
like curlier exclamation points.
>>San Mehat: I don't have an update from the
connectivity team on that, but we can certainly
dig into it.
>>Chris DiBona: Okay.
There was a battery optimizing but it dropped
down. Do you want to talk about power optimization,
anyone? It's not good enough, I guess.
It's hard sometimes to synthesize a real question
from a half question, so why don't we just
go to you.
>>> Hi. I work for a company who is an OHA
member. As a developer, do you have any benefit
being an OHA member? What additional information
I get compared to a normal developer?
>>San Mehat: You didn't get the card?
>>Chris DiBona: Can you speak up a bit?
>>> I said I work for a company who is a OHA
member. As a developer, what additional benefit
I get in the Android forum?
>>Chris DiBona: Why use Android over something
else? Is that what you are asking?
>>> Open hand set alliance.
>>Chris DiBona: Oh, what's the point of being
an OHA member. Is that right?
>>> Yes.
>>Chris DiBona: Sorry. It's the bounce sound
thing.
What's that?
Yeah, we're not really OHA folks. So it's
hard for us to answer that. I'm sorry.
>>> Okay. I have one more question.
>>Dave Sparks: You probably want to contact
either Eric Chu or Angana Ghosh. They are
here somewhere.
>>Chris DiBona: Eric, are you here? Raise
your hand.
I guess he is not in the room.
>>Dave Sparks: Bailed on us.
But they can give you a breakdown on what
OHA is about.
I think it's really, it's a commitment to
Android and the idea of CTS and Market and
really growing the Android ecosystem. That's
what it's all about. It's a commitment from
those companies to push Android.
>>> Okay. I have one more question. Cupcake,
Donut and Eclair and now Froyo. Android has
moved a bit. However, it's still stuck with
2.6.29. And I see there are a lot of developers
who are migrating to 2.6.3 on their own and
there are a lot of duplicative efforts being
spent. Is there any reason why Google has
not moved to 2.6.31?
>>> I did not catch --
>>San Mehat: Oh, the kernel? Oh, you are wondering
why we haven't snapped our kernel forward
to 2.6.31?
>>> That's right.
>>Chris DiBona: Bryan?
>>Brian Swetland: Why what about 31?
>>San Mehat: They want to know --
>>Brian Swetland: We try to aggressively track
and snap up to the main line as it rolls forward,
but this has to happen relative to release
cycles.
The software -- We don't finish Froyo and
then OTA it the next day, it pencils down
the next day.
There's a stabilization period on a release
that could be a month or two. We will tend
-- We will probably never ship a production
device against a kernel that's not final.
We won't ship against RC3 or something.
So we will tend to ship against the latest
main line kernel that hit --
>>Chris DiBona: Four months ago, five months
ago.
>>Brian Swetland: Well, that was released
before we hit the last, say, month or two
of stabilization for the release cycle.
So the Froyo software image for Nexus One
is based on 2.6.32. We are actively developing
against 2.6.34 RC. We will be snapping up
to 34 momentarily. Gingerbread this fall will
probably be at least against 35, maybe 36,
depending on where the schedule falls.
But we try to track it aggressively, but we
do stabilize the kernel before we ship. And
oftentimes, well, the rapid progress of the
main line brings in great bug fixes that we
want to pick up and new features, various
subsystems can destabilize as well or code
needs to shift around to compensate for it.
So just timing.
>>> Timing.
>>Dan Bornstein: And actually you see this
throughout Android. At the higher levels,
for things like ICU, and open SSL, and there's
all sorts of libraries at every layer.
And we won't get, if it was released yesterday,
it's not going to make it into Froyo today.
There's definitely a time period of making
sure that the new version is stable enough
and it's going to work, and it's really, you
know, -- it is a matter of months between
a stable release of an external library until
it, like, lands in Android.
>>Brian Swetland: The one thing I would say,
and I have said this to a number of OEMs and
silicon vendors who ask me about this, nothing
stops you from using a later spin of the kernel
if you like for your release. But I suspect
that most entities that do software release
for consumer products go through a similar
stabilization period.
Actually, a lot of consumer gear I see shipping
Linux I think still uses, like, 2.4, early
2.6. I think we are fairly aggressive at tracking
main line compared to a lot of efforts.
>>> It's John Cory at US Naviguide.
There are a lot of Web sites like Circuit
and AndroLib that use the market APIs kind
of under the hood. What are you are thoughts
on opening up both the web-based market API
and the device API for the market to users
-- to developers?
>>Michael Morrissey: As you saw this morning
in this morning's keynote, we are building
our own Web site, and that's something that's
very important to us. And along with that,
we do want to expose more data to sites in
the form of feeds.
That's something that we're looking at, and
we'll definitely let people know as soon as
we have that.
>>> What about on the device itself?
There's one developer came up with this really
kind of great idea for checking to see if
an app had actually been downloaded from the
Market. It's like a license check. It's very
simple. All you do is ask the Market, are
you my source? And if the answer is yes, then
it's a valid app. If the answer is no, then
it's a pirated app.
He is using some under-the-hood stuff that's
not exposed publicly.
It sounds like a really good, simple way to
solve the piracy problem, or at least part
of it.
And I wouldn't use it because it's not public,
but if it was made public, I think that could
be a really easy way to solve part of the
piracy problem.
>>Michael Morrissey: Right. So as I said earlier,
there's some things that we're working on
internally right now to combat the piracy
issue, and we'll definitely announce that
as soon as we have something that developers
can use.
>>> Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: There's a question. It feels
like it's really for Eric Chu's panel earlier
about adoption curves for 2.2. Should we just
leave that for -- Yeah, sorry.
Why don't we go with a question -- did I go
that side last time? Here, yeah.
>>> I wanted to know if you have thought of
using the GPU to enhance the user experience.
For example, for the Android system and for
the browser.
>>Mike Cleron: Yes, and that's his job right
there (indicating.)
>>Chris DiBona: It's all his fault.
>>Mike Cleron: We want to dramatically up
our game in terms of the animation speed,
performance frame rate of our drawing system.
We have got our best guys on it, so that's
something we're working on right now.
>>> It's going to happen after Froyo?
>>Chris DiBona: It's going to be happening
for the (inaudible) product. That's not the
kind of thing that's going to happen with
any one release.
>>Mike Cleron: He said he wants a vacation,
so I don't know.
>>> I am fine with that. Thanks.
>>Dan Bornstein: Sir.
>>> On the marketplace, you have basically
got a one-direction channel of communication
from the users in the form of comments, and
no real good way to communicate back to them
or, you know, really reply to them. Somebody
says, oh, it's not working. How do you get
the connection to them to say, well, let me
help fix that?
>>> (speaking off mic).
>>Michael Morrissey: So I think one of the
best approaches that you can take is to fill
out your developer information, the contact
information that it does appear in Market.
So with every listing in Market, you can add
Web sites for support and things like that,
and I think that's the way that most developers
find is the most effective to talking back
to their users.
>>> Well, I have done that. Admittedly, I
don't have all that many downloads. But I
have gotten, I think, one comment through
that mechanism, and a number of comments in
the marketplace.
So I don't think the users are clicking through
on those very much.
>>Chris DiBona: Darn users.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah.
>>> Are there plans to compete with the iPad?
>>Chris DiBona: You mean take flash off of
2.2?
[ Applause ]
>>Chris DiBona: Oh, a....
Or do you mean to slow it down?
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: I don't think that -- you
know, whatever.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Does anyone actually want
to touch this? No.
>>Mike Cleron: I would, but I haven't heard
of that product, so sorry.
>>Chris DiBona: Sorry. We're not going to
go down that -- We are Android people. Ask
Apple what they are going to do with the iPad
and compete with us.
[ Laughter ]
>>> Okay. First of all, I would like to encourage
Android add tennis shoes issues because that
would give us the actual real realization
of the shoe phone.
Second of all, I have a question about hardware
access on the devices. Maybe I am just not
looking in the right place, how to have some
R & D projects, some friends and colleagues
that I work with who were interested in hooking
up various sensors to our devices. There are
admittedly very hackie ways and very convoluted
back-flippy kind of ways to do this.
Are there plans to make this easier? So we've
got generic I/O API calls even at the lower
level.
>>Chris DiBona: I would point out the Bluetooth
RM interfaces is the standardized API now;
right, Dan?
>>Dan Morrill: Yeah.
>>Chris DiBona: That's a limb hackie. You
can just do serial over Bluetooth. But there
are a lot of people who mess around.
>>Brian Swetland: Are you talking about access
to on-device peripherals or access to outbound
peripherals?
>>> Access on device peripherals. Like we
would like to hook up sensors to something
that speaks TTL serial to a USB to foo bridge
and then USB on the device to --
>>Brian Swetland: So we --
>>> Understand where I am heading; right?
>>Brian Swetland: We definitely have been
thinking about this. We don't have a concrete
timeline or plan, but some of the ideas that
we have kicked around and may explore in upcoming
releases involve we could expose sort of a
USB gadget API up even to the Java layer for
most, like, bulk USP. You don't need to be
that fast in order to do useful things with
it.
With the NDK, you are capable of just doing
the POSIX I/O, so you could bolt a little
library on to open and do I/O control calls
to things. We've occasionally kicked around
the idea of just having a sort of generic
device object, open/close I/O control at the
Java level, with the idea that platform integrators
could create -- could bolt these on and you
could ask for them by name, and it would be
kind of a generic way to get at arbitrary
generic add-on devices.
These are all directions that we've thought
about. As I said, though, there's not a current
plan.
>>Chris DiBona: Like a B-box style breakout
board?
>>Brian Swetland: We are not planning on a
37-pin header at this point.
>>> But definitely, that's the direction I
would like to see it go.
>>Chris DiBona: He wants it.
>>Brian Swetland: I think it's a totally reasonable
request and it is something we are thinking
about for upcoming releases. But further suggestions
are always welcome.
>>> Okay. Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: Any way to have access to
staging server to push applications to before
they are submitted to the Android Market?
The goal is to test the update before it is
available to a large audience.
So like a private -- my own market channel.
>>Michael Morrissey: Yeah, this is --
>>Chris DiBona: A lot of implications for
the enterprise.
>>Michael Morrissey: Yes, this is an often-requested
feature and one that we are definitely prioritizing.
>>Chris DiBona: Cool.
Which side did I use last time? You.
>>> There's a tremendous amount of fragmentation
in OS version that different device manufacturers
and carriers are using.
>>Dan Morrill: I would thank you not to use
the "F" word in my presence; okay?
No, no. I don't spend a whole a lot of time
thinking about fragmentation because the problem
is this word means something different to
everybody.
I will see blogs say Android is fragmented
because 1.5 and 1.6 are out at the same time.
If you consider something like desktop Windows,
nobody ever -- there are certainly legitimate
complaints about having, say, Windows 95 and
Windows XP available at the same time, but
nobody ever called that fragmentation.
So I don't treat this word as something that
I spend a lot of time thinking about.
What I think about is really kind of two sorts
of things. One is whether or not applications
that are written to the Android APIs will
run across devices, and then the other is,
you know, whether they --
>>Chris DiBona: Everyone's 6 machine.
>>Dan Morrill: It's basically cross-device
capability and forward capability.
If you write an application for Android 1.5,
it's going to run on 1.6, 2.1, 2.2, and so
on. So the way I like to explain this is,
I imagine a highway, and you're a developer
driving a car down this highway.
Some platforms will say, okay. Here's a perfectly
manicured highway, perfectly paved. There
are no potholes.
But it's two lanes wide, and there's traffic
cops every 75 feet, you know, to make sure
that you don't go faster than they want you
to go.
I like to think of Android as more of something
like a five-lane highway where the middle
three or four lanes are totally clear and
you can kind of do your thing.
But if you want to go really fast and be on
the bleeding edge, you can be on the left-hand
lane. And if you want to be conservative,
you can be on the right-hand lane or the shoulder,
but the highway is not going to be as well
maintained there, so there's a risk.
But what we do is make sure those middle three
lanes are well paved and developers who are
just writing apps that are using the public
APIs, these will work in future versions.
So that's really kind of the commitment we
make, and that's what we think of when we
think of device compatibility and so on.
So I don't use this fragmentation word very
much, because it's diluted, but --
>>Chris DiBona: But it's fun to use against
all platforms, though.
You can talk about crapping iPad apps into
iPhones going back to the first-generation
iPhones and they're not going to run.
You can do this up and down Windows mobile
whatever version they're on now, the Kin.
So you get into this spot where fragmentation
happens, and as developers, we have to deal.
But our job is to make that dealing not so
horrible, you know.
>>Mike Cleron: Just to add to what Dan said,
two things.
Where we are not meeting that objective, where
something doesn't run on all 1.6 devices,
we definitely want to hear about that.
Where you wrote something against 1.6, you
did it all right and didn't cheat and use
APIs that you weren't supposed to use.
And it was written cleanly against the SDK
and broke in 2.0, that's on us to fix and
we want to hear about it.
But the other connotation of fragmentation,
1.5 to 1.6 to 2.0 to 2.1 to 2.2, I prefer
the term "progress" over "fragmentation" for
that phenomenon.
>>> A couple of questions.
Is there an SDK for Google TV that -- is there
a box or is there an emulator?
How do you develop for it?
>>Chris DiBona: You're not going to see much
about that until it looks like late this year
or early next year, including open source
release of the full platform.
So patience is the only thing we can count
on.
>>> And a short real question for Dave.
So currently, the only way of playing back
streaming video from what I've seen you talk
about online is RTSP/RTP.
When is that going to change?
Is there any different in Froyo?
>>David Sparks: No, there isn't anything changed
in Froyo.
In fact, Froyo for RTSP stack is the same
as the previous one, Eclair.
But in the next release, we're planning to
support some things, like we're looking at
live streaming, we're looking at exposing
the stacks so you can do your own network
streaming protocol on top of the codecs.
So, essentially, expose the top of the codecs,
send elementary streams to the codecs, and
have the framework take care of AV sync and
all the rest of it.
So this is definitely something we want to
support.
>>> Okay.
Thank you.
>>> The 2.2 SDK came out today.
That's great.
But I guess in addition to that, some fixes
were made to methods that didn't change but
the documentation was just crummy, such as
service intents.
In the future, could you not do that, like,
just push the fixes out to the documentation
as fast as possible?
>>Chris DiBona: Docs are out of date compared
to the SDK.
And he wants you to stop doing that.
[ Laughter ]
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Can you repeat the question?
Sorry.
>>Chris DiBona: Your Docs are out of date
to the SDK.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: So we're --
>>Chris DiBona: We're playing telephone.
Go ahead.
>>> There were fixes made to the SDK, but,
like, those fixes were bundled with the version
released for 2.2.
And it seems like that fix could have come
as soon as it was made and not on a big release
date like Google I/O.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Do you have an example
of that fix?
>>> Service intents.
And in an earlier session today, they gave
an example where it was just one paragraph
and nobody knew how to use it, and --
>>Xavier Ducrohet: Oh, for the documentation.
>>> Intent service.
Excuse me.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: We can definitely update
the online version more often.
We can also update the offline version more
often now.
I think that there's a lot of things on the
developer side that is not documented properly,
and I think we are just catching up with that
at this point.
So whenever we have, like, new API documentation,
it's mostly also catching up with the new
ones for the next version.
So if that ever slows down a little bit, maybe
we'll be able to go back and improve that.
It's mostly bandwidth issue at this point.
>>> Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: I'm going to combine the next
two questions from the computer.
Will the G1 ever been updated to 21st or higher,
and talk about testing on -- to 2.1 or higher?
And talk about testing, what are your pain
points?
>>Dan Bornstein: You need big pockets.
Multiple devices.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chris DiBona: Do you have a better answer?
So Froyo on G1s?
>>David Sparks: Technically not really feasible.
The problem is that Flash space on the G1
is too small.
So we just can't get Froyo to fit on Flash.
>>Brian Swetland: Basically, yeah, it would
require removing existing features to make
room.
You know, you're going to have to cut or you're
going to have to do some drastic things.
I suspect what will happen is you'll see the
external community building some different
custom ROMs for it.
The difficulty with the device that's around
two years old now and, again, due to the Flash
size limits, it's hard to roll in the new
release without potentially removing functionality
that existing users, end users, expect to
have.
>>Chris DiBona: Yeah.
And this is a legitimate roll for them to
have.
This is one of the reasons why we open sourced
it, was to help folks like that with old hardware.
So do you want to talk about how painful it
is to support multiple devices?
There's 50 of them out.
>>> It takes forever to build on them all.
>>Chris DiBona: You can hit the button at
once.
You don't have to wait --
>>> The.
>>David Sparks: The question is how difficult
it is for the platform to work across multiple
devices?
>>> I think it might be more about the application
side.
>>David Sparks: We rely on manufacturers to
do their own application testing.
We recommend things that we actually -- I
think the developer relations team has done
a pretty good job of figuring out these are
the top 100 apps, you should probably work
with those.
CTs is does a lot of that work for us.
And in cases where we've seen an app that
was broken in a release and CTS didn't catch
it, we try to go back and fix CTS so that
it will catch it next time.
But we can't go out and test, you know, 55
devices or whatever the number is today, so
we do have to rely on the manufacturers.
What we do is, through our partner relations
group, if we get a report that there's a problem,
we work directly with the manufacturer to
help them fix it, help them understand what
the problem is, and push out a release.
>>Mike Cleron: So I think for the application
side of that, there's a very impressive cabinet
full of devices.
It's not our intent that you have to buy one
of those and try your application on every
single one, because --
>>Chris DiBona: I mean, if you want to.
>>Mike Cleron: Don't let me stop you.
But they might come out faster than you can
actually test them.
You may never actually catch up to the number
of devices being manufactured.
Instead, I think the right approach is to
look at the different axes in the test matrix.
So there's MDPI devices and HDPI devices,
there's with and without hard keyboard, portrait
and landscape.
And if you cover that, which you can do with
maybe two devices or a couple devices in the
emulator, then you have pretty high confidence
that you're going to run everywhere.
MDPI on one device is the same as MDPI on
another.
Landscape on one is the same as landscape
on another.
That's what I was talking about earlier about
trying to keep the surface area relatively
compact even if we want to support a lot of
variations on the theme.
So you don't by any means have to test exhaustively
on every piece of hardware.
It's not possible.
>>Chris DiBona: So what are -- what are the
plans to support streaming H264 content, not
just local, but streaming.
I know one of the answers is you can do it
Flash now.
>>> Streaming.
>>Chris DiBona: I guess from a Web site or
something.
>>David Sparks: Streaming in general?
We support HTP progressive streaming already.
I talked earlier about live streaming, something
we're looking at.
And RTSP, I'm not sure what else you're looking
for.
Like I say, with the next release, we're expecting
to be able to allow applications to put their
own protocol stack in place.
And this will solve some of the problems.
There are a lot of people running proxy servers
on device so they can do whatever protocol
they want to do.
We should theoretically eliminate that in
the next release.
>>> This morning in the Google TV demo, we
saw a lot of new UI controls, and I've also
heard a lot of news about major manufacturers
kind of stepping up their tablet initiatives.
I know you can't talk in depth about what's
in Gingerbread.
But can you speak a little bit to the strategies
for possibly different sets of UI widgets
for the different kind of environments that
Android will be running in?
>>Chris DiBona: UI widget theming?
>>Mike Cleron: Yesterday, Jim Palmer spoke
about UX in general.
We're looking to do ongoing refreshes of our
UI.
I think our philosophy is more to make something
that works across the span of devices rather
than have, you know, a small phone UI, a big
phone UI, potentially one day a tablet UI,
a TV UI, things like that.
Because that will just make the developers'
lives harder.
Because if they want to soffit with the system
theme, that gives one more axis that they
have to vary on.
So we're looking to have something that can
work well across a range of devices and a
range of screen sizes.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Regarding the communication with the Android
developers and the contributions from the
community, yesterday, I got approved one small
patch to the Android OS system.
I really appreciate that, and I really appreciate
the work of JPQ and the other people who are
integrating these patches.
The only point is that it took a little bit
more than one year to get reviewed and integrated.
So I would like to know if Google has plans
to improve the situation to -- well, to work
more tightly with the community.
>>Chris DiBona: So bringing down the patch
flow from a year to 11 months.
>>Brian Swetland: Less than a year would definitely
be good.
JBQ's team is actively working to improve
that.
We've been staffing up that team.
JBQ, you know, started by himself, and he
has some other folks helping him now.
And we're also working to get core team engineers
involved in reviews of external patches.
We definitely want to improve the process
of getting external contributions in.
It's good for everybody to do so.
>>Dan Morrill: Yeah, and kind of beyond that,
right now -- well, the first thing I understand
that Android isn't just a single project.
It's actually, I think, the current number
is something close to 230 projects, many of
which are external, meaning that we pull them
from upstream.
But most of the rest are ours.
But we've got at least, like, probably 150,
I think, you know, unique projects that are
Android projects.
Right now, our development process is that
those are all what I'll say, like, the work
occurs first in our internal server and then
gets periodically pushed to the external server.
Over time, we're actually moving some of the
-- some of the individual projects to the
external tree.
In fact, the SDK team just switched not long
ago.
That work was done on the open tree first.
So that will speed some of these up.
You specifically referred to the patches.
JBQ actually, as it happens, last week and
through this week has made a big pass on those.
And I think right now he said there's about
180 that are still open.
And I think at one point, there were -- I
think the peak was somewhere about 500.
And so it is true that it certainly does take
some time for us to get to some patches.
But these are the things that we're doing
to kind of work on that.
We're moving some projects open, which reduces
the sort of impedance mismatch between code
that we're writing and code that people are
contributing.
And we're also working to get more -- more
of the engineers looking at the public issue
-- or the public garrote instance.
Another thing that we actually just did, this
site relaunch that I keep mentioning. One
thing that we also turned on was a couple
new lists. One thing we discovered was a bit
problematic is we only had one list, mailing
list, I mean, whose purpose was to discuss
patches and manage this kind of thing. And
it filled up with noise because if you only
have one list, then everything gets discussed
in one list.
So we actually created two new mailing lists
the other day, and I hope maybe perhaps you
will consider joining them. But one of them
is called Android building which is specifically
for questions about how to build the source
tree and about the build system. And the intent
here is let's move all that discussion, which
turns out to be a pretty percentage of the
chatter on Android platform, into that list.
And, similarly, we created a list called Android
Contrib which is for contributors specifically
discussing patches. And hopefully by this
way, what we will allow -- or what we will
enable is to make it easier for the engineers
to actually triage this work, and instead
of having to troll through this gigantic morass
of e-mail messages, 80% which have don't interest
them, they can specifically look at these
lists which are maintained as working lists.
It's a bit of an experiment. We're going to
try and we're going to be super aggro about
moderating these things. We're not going to
really tolerate any off-topic discussions
on these two lists to keep the signal-to-noise
ratio high so work can get done.
So we are aware of this. It's something we
are spending more time trying to improve that
flow and get patches in from the outside.
>>>Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: We probably only have time
for one last question.
>>> My question is about in order to get the
AOSP working on an actual device, that generally
means needing hardware drivers that aren't
open source, and that's not exactly Android's
problem or Google's problem, but is there
anything that your team is doing or encouraging
manufacturers or anything in order to reduce
the barrier to getting the AOSP on a device
when you are not a big company that can swing
deals with other big companies?
>>Dan Morrill: Yeah, it is actually my extreme
pleasure -- We totally hear that. In fact,
this has been a huge, huge issue getting AOSP
to run vanilla on a device for a long time.
Froyo goes an extremely long way towards that
goal.
The reality is that we had some technical
problems in the actual code that made this
a difficult proposition in Eclair. But when
the Froyo source code is released, which will
be in the coming weeks, it will be vastly
easier. And, in fact, you can do it. You can
build a full vanilla Android open source tree,
install it on a Nexus One. There are some
binaries that you still need because, unfortunately,
not all software can be open sourced, but
you can build a vanilla tree with the Froyo
source code and boot it and run and make a
phone call.
So it's a huge milestone for us and we're
super excited about it.
>>Brian Swetland: That's the result of a number
of things. We are actively working with the
silicon vendors like Qualcomm, and T.I., and
so on, to encourage them to support GPLV2,
like as many drivers as possible open source.
And also, to -- when that's not possible,
we're trying to work with them to enable the
delivery of things like the user space OpenGL
library, which is a common component that
for various reasons is rarely open, but to
make it available to community developers
so you don't have to jump through a lot of
hoops.
I think in particular, Nexus One, the number
of closed binary packages is remarkably small
for --
>>Chris DiBona: Down to nine for 2.1. I don't
know if it's smaller than that now.
>>Brian Swetland: There are reportedly much
more open devices that I have seen 20, 30,
40 --
>>Chris DiBona: 90.
>>Brian Swetland: -- as far as lists of binary
packages.
So it's definitely not perfect. We would love
to see a world where the entire thing would
build completely open. But we are actively
working with the various OHA partners and
other contributors to get as close as we possibly
can.
>>> Thank you.
>>Chris DiBona: And that's where we end today's
fireside, so....
[ Applause ]